[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu nunca contei pra minha namorada da
época mas quando eu virei pra ela e
perguntei numa tarde dessas que parece
que o tempo nunca vai passar se ela
continuaria mandando se eu fosse um
homem estava repetindo uma cena que eu
tinha lido numa história histórias e as
comunidades em que os encontrei foram
parte fundamental para que eu entendesse
como pessoa trans mas a história que eu
quero começar ou contar pra vocês hoje
veio muito muito antes desta tarde
é preciso começar dizendo que eu sou uma
criança dos anos 90 isso significa que
eu cresci junto com a internet
independente da velocidade de acesso eu
sempre fui atrás das histórias que as
pessoas poderiam me contar seja trocando
blogs na madrugada internet discada com
os meus amigos até dezenas de vídeos que
eu posso ver hoje semanalmente do
youtube
essas redes de histórias sempre me
inspiraram a encontar representações do
que eu podia ser talvez porque quando eu
olhava pra vida real era muito difícil
encontrar a representação para ser uma
pessoa lgbt
se você for olhar por exemplo os filmes
têm uma associação americana que chama
glad e eles olham para a
representatividade lgbt nos filmes
feitos pelas maiores produtoras de barro
em 2016 nos filmes feitos por essas
produtoras só 18% tinham personagens
lgbt e entre esses menos de um terço
eram mulheres e só uma personagem era
uma personagem trans
se a gente olhar para o cenário
brasileiro a situação fica muito melhor
a revista superinteressante fez um
levantamento das personagens lgbt nas
novelas brasileiras
de 2010 para cá foram 57 personagem
cerca de 25 produções como base de
comparação só maior emissora brasileira
produziu 43 novelas no mesmo período com
cerca de 20 personagens de cada um
é fácil entender como no começo da minha
adolescência nos anos 2000 era muito
difícil para mim
mim entender que duas mulheres podiam se
apaixonar uma pelas outras e que o único
conhecimento que eu tinha sobre gênero
idade eram sobre travestis trabalhadoras
sexuais que nem tinham a sua identidade
reconhecida mas é um assunto que eu
dominava nessa época
harry potter graças à internet banda
larga e você me podia encontrar qualquer
dia depois da aula
lendo e debatendo em fóruns da internet
sobre o mundo mágico e todas as
possibilidades que tinham e foi numa
dessas viagens que eu encontrei as fãs
fictions histórias de ficção escritas
por fãs e pessoas que estavam seu tempo
criando destinos alternativos
personagens ou expandindo os universos
originais e por algum motivo
pessoas-chave fanfictions tem uma certa
obsessão por personagens lgbt
talvez exatamente por não encontrar os
personagens em outro lugar
abrir um novo mundo de possibilidades
pra mim
pela primeira vez eu consegui ler uma
história sobre duas mulheres que se
apaixonavam e tinha um relacionamento
saudável e aí no auge dos meus 13 anos
eu comecei a olhar para os meus
sentimentos e ver que talvez o que eu
sentia por aquela menina da minha turma
não é só assim não de amizade talvez
fosse uma outra coisa bem tempo foi
passando e ficando mais histórias
conhecendo novas redes e não só eu li
essas histórias que eu podia conversar
com as pessoas que chegam elas e online
me dava uma possibilidade que eu nunca
tinha tido na vida real que era uma vez
uma conversa ficava muito difícil ela
podia acabar lhe era tão fácil quando
saí do chat e procurar a história
seguinte e procurar conversa seguinte
o tempo foi passando a minha
adolescência foi passando fui me
tornando cada vez mais confortável com a
minha sexualidade fui pesquisando
encontrei um rótulo que pra mim mais faz
sentido que é pão sexual que se sente
atraído pelas pessoas independente de
gênero mas pensar sobre gênero ainda
levou um bom tempo então a gente chega
em 2017 e um jovem adulto bem sucedido
experiências incríveis um currículo
lindo em depressão e não da pressão no
sentido do tipo atua faculdades e que
fazer com a minha vida mas de pressão no
sentido osório esqueceu como é que
produz serotonina e ele só sabe como
cria mais motivos para o odiar
eu não tinha muita energia para fazer
outras coisas então eu gostava muito
tempo na minha cama novamente
pesquisando mais umas histórias
histórias de pessoas que tinham
depressão que viviam com ansiedade ou
que simplesmente estavam fora do padrão
do padrão de saúde mental padrão de
corpos dos padrões de gênero sexualidade
dos padrões das normas sociais qualquer
formato que encontrava vídeos conta de
quadrinhos
eu queria consumir eu queria entender o
que era tudo aquilo e aí foi a primeira
vez que eu me deparei com a história de
uma pessoa não binária não binária uma
pessoa que não se identifica no binário
de gênero nem como homem e nem como
mulher e foi lendo sobre as experiências
daquela pessoa daquela personagem que
alguma coisa clicou dentro de mim eu
comecei a entender que talvez eu
precisasse voltar e pensar sobre a
questão de gênero ea primeira coisa que
eu descobri foi que ser 3 no brasil é
muito difícil
o brasil é o país que mais mata pessoas
transitáveis x no mundo isso é só um dos
indicadores da realidade brasileira
porque eu ia querer fazer parte de um
grupo que heath toda vítima de violência
e discriminação porque eu queria é
pensar sobre uma coisa que tirar de mim
o privilégio de ser entendido no gênero
que tinha sido assim designado horas e
sempre tenha sido um pouco fora do
padrão mas ainda assim era muito
diferente
a gente chega naquela tarde em que pela
primeira vez eu disse em voz alta que eu
não sou mulher
não consigo me enxergar como uma que
talvez eu nunca tenha sido mas falar pra
pessoa que eu amo no momento de
intimidade era só o primeiro passo para
que pudesse viver da forma mais
autêntica
vou contar pra todo mundo então eu fiz
isso da única forma que um jovem milena
eu poderia fazer com post nas redes
sociais
a verdade é que eu não esperava a
resposta que eu recebi foi tanto amor
tanto carinho tanto as respostas de
coragem é eu chorei muitas vezes lendo
as mensagens e chora até hoje todas as
vezes que eu lembro dessa história mas
eu acho que o melhor não foi só o que as
pessoas vieram falar sobre mim mas
quando as pessoas vieram compartilhar de
próprias histórias
pessoas que eu conhecia pessoas que eu
não conhecia que eram próximas não tão
próximas amigos de amigos e conhecidos
que um dia talvez eu tenha cruzado num
evento do ted que queriam falar sobre as
reflexões que tinham tido as dúvidas que
tinham as repercussões e aí pra mim
ficou muito claro que tudo bem ter
dúvidas
tudo bem não saber tudo bem se
questionar e tudo bem se descobrir e que
essas redes fazem partes de novas redes
que a gente vai gerando então é eu fui
buscando cada vez mais e mais histórias
para me encontrar
é dentro das histórias que procurei no
youtube por exemplo pra mim foram muito
fortes muitos exemplos
eu fui encontrar slayer world é que
conseguiu mobilizar mais de mil pessoas
para contar sobre as suas experiências
nas suas descobertas sobre identidade de
gênero é jardel que vai falar sobre como
faz parte de dúvidas não entender e
mudar de ideia quando você vai explorar
a sua própria sexualidade a sua própria
identidade de gênero eo canadá já um
homem transbrasiliano que vai falar
sobre a realidade e transbrasil e as
dificuldades de ter os seus direitos
sendo sendo válidos né então as
histórias são muito grandes e quando
chegam e quando eu conto a minha
história eu reparo que eu estou abrindo
uma porta não só pra mim mas para outras
pessoas eu acho importante quanto a isso
porque a minha história foi de muito
a sorte eu tive acesso ao conhecimento
que eu precisava para me entender
eu tenho uma família que me ama e que me
aceito como eu sou eu tivemos amizade
que me apoiaram quando eu achei que eu
não ia mais conseguir eu tive as redes
dentro e fora da internet que me
permitiram chegar até aqui mas essa não
é a realidade da maior parte da
comunidade lgbt
quando eu olho para estes números
eu sei que ainda tem muito o que precisa
ser feito
existem muitos espaços e muitas redes
sendo construídas que permitem as
pessoas se entendam sintam acolhidas se
descubram mas existe um caminho muito
grande para que essas redes sejam
transpostos e saiam de pequenos locais
saiu só na internet e venham para a vida
real
é por isso que todas as vezes que eu
tenho a oportunidade de contar minha
história eu conto não como se fosse só
minha mas como se eu pudesse abrir
espaço para que várias outras vozes que
hoje não podem ou não conseguem usar os
próprios votos pra falar tenho esse
espaço para que as comunidades lgbt para
que as pessoas possam é as pessoas lgbts
identidades lgbt sejam entendidas sejam
espalhadas não só em redes dentro da
internet
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i